[Music]
Shannon beador is back I'm good how are
you good season 13 I know it's crazy
you're putting single shannon out there
this year who is single shannon fun I
feel like I'm back so to speak did you
feel like you had lost the part of
yourself
oh absolutely this is just been who I
know I think it's time to say throwing
on I was a big proponent of keeping my
marriage together and now that we aren't
together as unfortunate as it is it is
the best and only decision and I would
never want to go back to that marriage
what kind of relationship do you and
David have today not a good one but
that's okay
you know hopefully someday we'll be in
that better amicable position when a
couple months we'll have everything
settled and so they'd be done once that
is officially done
clothes chapter finished chapter
finished never to be reopened or reread
I am frickin more nervous right now to
walk into a blind date I need to get to
know somebody before you get to do this
we're gonna see you date this year on
the show yes how long did you wait from
the split going maybe I should get back
out well you know I didn't do anything
for about six months and I didn't go out
once not even out to dinner just kind of
stayed by myself and it was miserable
and it was painful but I felt that I
needed to go through something like that
to be at peace with myself do you feel
at peace with your sick do they do what
was it after that time what changed that
you finally felt ready to get back out
there I saw David in court and I didn't
even feel anger towards them I just felt
like you know that I didn't really feel
much which is crazy after you spend
almost 20 years with somebody it's not
like I want to hop back into the serious
relationship but I open to dating I'm
excited about it it's
it's gonna fun are you dating to find a
life partner or just for fun right now
well I would love to someday be married
with someone who's my partner and like
the team I'm on my team we're a team
what boxes need to be checked what's on
the Shannon beador man wishlist smart
sense of humor easygoing really in love
with me and just a kind a kind person I
think that's really it you know I don't
know I it'll just all know those aren't
huge I don't know just you know I just
want someone that that respects me and
respects our relationship whatever that
lady did you realize how all your life
would be without marriage you know what
it's it's quite refreshing
it really is I'm kind of proud of where
where I've come so far if you had to sum
up season 13 with just one word what
would it be
I'm gonna say growth change I'm having a
lot of fun with the new identity yeah
single punch and this year
cheers to that Cheers Congrats on
surviving another season thank you
[Applause]
you